BRENNAN SAETA: TPUs
are making an excuse
of "my model is training"
a thing of the past.
Looking to learn a bit
more about how they work?
Well, you've come
to the right place.
With over 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
"Programming ML Supercomputers:
A Deep Dive on Cloud
TPUs," then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This session was a
real treat, a chance
to hear about Tensor Processing
Units, or TPUs, directly
from a member of the
Google Brain team.
The session was broken up
into three main parts--
the life of a TPU program,
which talks about what
happens under the hood
when TPU programs are run,
writing a TPU program,
which talks about the API
for writing TPU
code, and, finally,
feeding a TPU program,
which is discussing how
to get your data into the TPU
fast enough to really utilize
its powerful
number-crunching abilities.
TPUs were made to combat the
exponentially-rising amount
of compute required to train
state-of-the-art machine
learning models in recent years.
And it's iterating pretty quick.
TPUv3 has already come out,
barely a year after version 2.
TPU chips have a powerful
matrix multiplier at their core.
And in the TPU version 2,
which is available, today,
as Cloud TPUs, there are four
TPU chips on a single board.
Now, these boards are
then arranged into pods
of 64 TPU boards each.
Today, you can get
access to a TPU
with just a couple
of GCloud commands.
And actually, writing
code from the TPU
involves using some wrappers
around the TensorFlow estimator
API, called TPUEstimators.
These wrappers help convert
your existing TensorFlow program
into something that
can be run on the TPU
utilizing the TF to XLA bridge.
There are some
limitations, of course,
such as requiring static
shapes for your arrays
and only being able to use
a subset of the operations
that TensorFlow can express.
But in exchange, you
get terrific speed.
How fast?
It's fast enough that,
if you hook it up
to an SSD hard
drive, the hard drive
won't be able to supply
the data fast enough.
So instead, we turn to
high-performance distributed
systems.
One option is Google
Cloud Storage.
You want to use
regional buckets,
with your data converted
to TFRecord format,
and the file split into
one to 200 megabyte chunks.
Another option is
to use Bigtable,
which has great performance,
straight-out-of-the-box,
up to 10x that of Cloud
Storage, sometimes.
TPUs, they're pretty amazing.
They're like time
machines in ways, right?
Instead of waiting
for days or weeks,
even, you can iterate
in hours or faster.
This supercharges ML research as
well as ML product development.
And as we continue to bring
you these improvements,
in compute power, storage
capability, and networking,
the sky is the limit.
So develop your
applications ethically,
conduct your
research responsibly,
and I am super excited to
see what you build with TPUs.
Thanks for watching
this Cloud "Rewind."
If you like this video,
give it a thumbs up.
And I've included the
link to the full talk
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
for more great content.
And I'll see you on
the next "Rewind."
[MUSIC PLAYING]